regardez la qualité rédactionnelle même
sous l'Ancien Régime quand vous
prononce des mariages regardez l'article
212 et 215 qui date de l'ancien régime
comme c'est limpide les épouses doivent
mutuellement respecter fidélité ce cours
et assistance on comprend les articles
215 les égouts obligent mutuellement une
communauté de vie c'est génial c'est pas
une définition du mariage mais c'est une
condition sinequanone du mariage oui je
suis à la bourre et si il y a rupture de
la communauté de vie à rupture du
mariage et c'est opérationnel dans un
prétoire dans un tribunal
regardez les lois qu'aujourd'hui
regardez comme tu dis enfin vous disiez
monsieur le rapporteur tout à l'heure
mais moi je me mets à votre place mais
je la loi 3DS c'était affreux
et pourtant ça part que de bonnes
intentions mais c'est terrible
c'est-à-dire que regarder sur Lausanne
la loi climat est résilience CMP
conclusive la plus longue de l'histoire
à ma connaissance on est la loi les
décrets de la loi ne sont à peine ce
sont pas encore sortis et ceux qui sont
sortis sur l'attaquer au Conseil d'État
à juste titre par
la MF et le dire c'est qu'on est déjà
obligé de faire une autre loi grâce à
vous
pour détricoté cette loi qui est
inapplicable loi a fragmentation
bureaucratique
inapplicable je parle comme Lucky loi a
fragmentation biocratique et donc là
dessus la différenciation c'est ce qu'on
nous donne quand il y a plus de
différence la différence c'est la vie la
vraie loi la bonne loi elle s'applique
partout sur le territoire national il
est applicable parce que elle correspond
à des dispositions générales mais
donnons un pouvoir d'application et
réglementaire collectivité territoriales
et on aura plus besoin de se poser ce
type de questions et on ne fera pas
d'usine à gaz parce qu'autrement la
différenciation deviendra un loi une loi
de la dérogation
et je suis sûr de ce que j'en suis sûr
et ça sera en fait ça favorisera je le
répète ceux qui auront l'ingénierie et
ceux qui ont la relation l'argent et la
relation